metro police are conducting a homicide
investigation on the east side of town
right near stuart and eastern
orco mana joins us live there now with
more on exactly what happened here
orco sasha it's still pretty active out
here with some metro squad cars and the
crime scene unit on scene
we're on marlin avenue and metro police
tell us this is where a woman shot her
neighbor to death earlier tonight
police say just after six o'clock this
evening they got multiple
man had been 911 in this area when
officers got here they found a black man
in his early 30's
suffering from one gunshot wound he was
taken to umc where he later died
detectives tell us the suspect described
as a black woman in her mid-30s
confronted the man who lived directly
across from her and a physical fight
started
during that fight she pulled out a gun
and shot him several other neighbors
then tackled her and were able to
wrestle the gun away
metro says this isn't the first time
these neighbors have had issues
there's been an ongoing dispute between
all the parties that live at the complex
ranging from a barking dog was
what indicated several of the arguments
have been over a barking dog
police say the suspect drove away from
the scene she left two children behind
and were told they're being put into the
care of child protective services
again police are still looking for this
woman so if you know anything about her
or about what happened here tonight
you're asked to call police or crime
stoppers where you can remain anonymous
reporting live in las vegas tonight orco
mana 8 news now